[Music]
john is with us in orlando hey john how
are you
hi how you doing
great man better than i deserve what's
up
uh well i um i'm gonna be uh with my
brother we're going to buy a furniture
business that my brother works at uh the
guy that owns it wants to retire and he
pretty much is
just wants to sell it for what he has in
inventory
but he wants a down payment on the
inventory of 75 000
um which i was going to
pay that aspect to me and my brother
were going to be partners in this
business
but my problem is i'm trying to figure
out what the best way to get my 75 000
back but we're also still partners so i
wasn't quite sure if i should put it on
a payment plan or if i should pay my
what would be the best way
to to take that investment back because
my brother's kind of bringing in the
sweat equity and he's going to be
running the business major the majority
of the time
but uh i just don't know how to go about
it i wanted to talk with you about it
so you're an absentee investor
of 75 000 into the business he's putting
nothing in it and he's gonna run it
yeah i would say i'm not total absentee
because i'll be helping with uh you know
the purchasing and doing a lot of the
books and and handle it on that end
and uh so i don't know if i'll be
totally absent but i think it would
probably be safe as maybe like a 70 30
split as far as the amount of work that
needs to be done
but the day-to-day he'll be doing
well the most fair way to do this the
proper way to do this is a little bit
complicated and you may not go for it
but i'll outline it for you okay
i would put a job description
on what each of you are going to be
doing and if you are going to hire
someone to do what that person is doing
he's the general manager you're the
bookkeeper slash purchaser part-time
right
and uh i would say okay that job if we
were to hire someone to do that would
pay
x and the other job would pay y and i
would pay you guys out of the business
for the work you're doing first
just like you had a job there
okay
okay then whatever profits are left i
would put a hundred percent of that back
in your pocket until your 75 000 is
returned
okay do you think also and that's
another thing is
out of let's say his inventory is a
quarter million dollars um so we're
gonna have a balance and he's gonna want
a percentage of that you know to be paid
within you know maybe two years
um
and he's he's doing it you know as far
as what kind of profit is this business
making
um
well i would say they're doing maybe
half a million dollars a year
so i think he's calling in maybe
out of profit maybe 125
maybe something maybe 150.
okay i don't like people investing money
and stuff when they say maybe i think
yeah
you don't know what you're doing
yeah we haven't got the whole you know
the open book situation i know what
their margins are i know like what their
average sales are i know what they're
over don't agree you know
get into the books before you make any
decisions but uh okay that's fine if we
say all right we're going to give him
50 of the profits until he gets the
balance
and we're going to give me 50 percent of
the profits until i get up to 75.
and after your 75's return i'd give him
100 of the profits until you get him out
of your life because then there's no
investor in the thing it's completely
free and clear you got your 75 back he
got his money out and then there's
profits then how are you going to split
those profits
50 50. i mean i'd like to be yeah i'd
like to be 50 50 with him i think that's
the fairest way to go if we're doing
this together
okay
all right well then you would continue
to make your income for the job you do
which then
you know obviously like you were paying
us an employee would lower the amount of
profit obviously not buy a lot but by
whatever that job pays
and um
and then you split the profits 50 50
after that you for being the investor
him from having brought the sweat and
the opportunity to the table to start
with
um
yeah that all makes sense now can i can
i step in a little bit further into the
weeds with you
yeah sure great okay
a couple of things that are danger areas
that you need to cover
one is you guys need to have a very
clear relational understanding up front
that when we're at work
he's the general manager you're the
purchasing agent and part-time
bookkeeper
you use your
general manager hat and voice
and bookkeeper hat and voice
not your brother voice
yeah
okay yeah that's the number one of my
concerns as well yeah well the way you
do it is you respect you respect the
person
yeah you don't you don't have two
brothers on the floor of the furniture
thing fighting like they're
nine-year-olds uh and the rest of the
employees watching and then wonder why
you can't keep good people
so you guys have to have a respect for
each other uh i'm the ceo of ramsey
solutions
rachel cruz is a ramsey personality my
daughter and when she's in this office
or we're working on business items she
treats me like the ceo and i treat her
like a ramsey personality like i would a
john delonia like i would a christy
wright
i treat them her with the same dignity i
don't use my dad voice on her and she
doesn't roll her eyes like a pendulum
teenager
right
correct and so you've got to get that
relational thing down that's item number
one you need to work on that that's a
big deal and you guys need to sit and
talk that through you may even want to
write out a little bit of a narrative
that you're both in agreement to just
for clarification on how you're going to
do that
and when you you know we can argue about
football over thanksgiving dinner
but we're not going to have you know a
big brother fight here the problem with
a 50 50 business is it's a two-headed
monster and nobody's in control
if you if you're going to split the
ownership of the business 50 50
after your stock after your 5000 75 000
is returned now area number two of
concern
do a detailed in-depth written with a
lawyer partnership agreement or don't do
this deal
and you have you have to cover all of
the possible negative things that can
happen and most of them begin with a d
divorce
death
disability
disinterest i'm no longer interested
default i just refuse to work but i'd
like to keep all the money
uh yeah drug use
uh would be the best kind of lawyer uh
what would you just a general a general
business
a lawyer that has a business practice
they're used to putting together it's
called a general partnership agreement
and what you cover is the negatives
because you don't want to be in business
with his wife if he dies
period even if you love her and she
think you think she's awesome that's not
the that's not what you're signing up
for
so what happens if he dies well you
probably need key man insurance on both
of you life insurance term life
insurance that buys
her out of his half if he dies
it leaves you
you're the owner of the policy but it's
used to make her to pay her
you get the money to buy her out and
that's preset ahead of time
and you can preset all that you know
that that's a normal process and this is
how you end up speaking to your brothers
still when you're 90 instead of hating
each other
because you have a plan for all the
downsides you have a way to respect each
other in the operation of this because
this is fraught with danger this whole
endeavor
there's a lot of downsides to this if
you don't do it right family business
can be wonderful but it can also be
cray-cray
and uh in studying family businesses
over the years i have noticed that the
family business is never more functional
than the family is
to the extent the family is
dysfunctional the family business is
screwed
and two brothers that are you know
obviously you like each other you
wouldn't be talking about this but there
are those times when you get under each
other's skin because you're brothers
that's how it works
and uh how are you going to manage
manage that conflict and how functional
are you in handling conflict with each
other
that's going to affect the business it's
going to destroy the business or it's
going to cause it to prosper
and we we work with theirs that here at
ramsey every day we work hard on it to
be able to keep things moving that's a
great question you asked thank you
a lot of different things a lot of
ground covered there for a bunch of you
listening on things to do
um
not a big fan of partnerships but if
you're going to do one with your brother
that's how you do it